in dessen zuge klassen aus ganz schweden
vorschläge für eine bessere zukunft
einreichen sollten auch wen auch wenn
teile ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge der minecraft heute am samstag ich
weiß sollte ich nicht freitag wollte es
auch nicht dienstag und dienstagabend
ein effekt und freitag lag einfach daran
dass ich diese woche wieder sehr viel
unterwegs war ich hatte viel zu tun mit
der uni und ich hab mir dann gedacht
haben dienstag kommen wir mal zu
dienstag ein effekt und gestern kam mir
das blondinenwitze video mit revue
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht kommen
dann mach ich doch einfach mal heute und
ich habe wieder fünf colfax am start
wenn es euch gefällt könnt ihr mir gerne
in die kommentare schreiben dass solch
gefällt oder mir per mail an kontakt zu
senden heute sind wieder fünf cool
effect zum start wird mich freuen wenn
ihr bis zum ende dran bleibt und anfang
märz kamen im ersten vers der erste
effekt wurde mir zugesendet von magix
routinier giggs und so schreibt er haye
conny wenn man eine redstone lampe ein
block in der luft schweben lässt und
dann einen fall dagegen schießt sondern
die lampe ein und wieder aus gerät der
gerät glitsch der fall durch das blog
update auf den boden okay gut ich hab
den kommentar so verstanden ihr seht
schon hier ist ein dorfbewohner
eingebaut dann habe ich einfach mal hin
gepflanzt unterdrücker ist eine redstone
lampe ich schieß diese redstone lampe ab
der feier hängt auch auf dem boden das
war sehr dumm dass der typ da ist und
nicht da drunter durch doch dass man ihm
ausgebessert und zwar haben wir jetzt da
hinten auch noch eine kuh am start
wir haben jetzt erstmal zwei billiger
und zwar ist der eine fall da unten und
ich jetzt mal einen fall auch unter ihr
us dollar mwp und ihr seht schon wenn
ich jetzt die lampen mache haben die
pfeile kurz und vibriert und wenn ich
die jetzt wieder einfacher fallen beide
pfeiler einfach unter
das geht auch wenn ich die lampe so an
mache ich schieß beispielsweise mal
wieder ein nach oben gegen einfach dass
der hier was will diese kuh dieses
irgendwie dieses neue münchen was mich
immer so besteuert also ein fall klingt
jetzt an der seite und dann schieße ich
einen fall noch an die einen fall noch
an die unterseite des blogs und jetzt
macht das wieder aus ihr seht schon ein
paar fältchen runter der eine da bleibt
doch ewig leben jetzt hält der andere
auch im grunde also das ist so ein
bisschen verpackt ein bisschen verglüht
keine ahnung man könnte damit bestimmt
einige coole sachen bauen irgendwie wenn
man jetzt den raps oder madonna sind
ganz ganz viele mops dann schießt man
damit vereinen darauf und drücken den
schaltern alle fallen alle sind tot und
ich weiß nicht was ich aber das feld
gemeinsam gefällt macht bevor wir zu
wecken hat zwei kommen nochmal ganz cool
es ist hier auf einmal so ein kleines it
can you know you und zwar ist dieser
zieht eigentlich ganz schnell ich also
ich bin hier vorne da auf dieser ecke
bin ich gespannt und ich dachte erst mal
so borger nur wasser dreh mich so und
jetzt echt einfach alles voll mit
irgendwelchen inseln und so ganz viele
inseln ist relativ cool gemacht ich gebe
euch den titel einfach mal sicher immer
sieht da steht da eingeblendet und jetzt
würde ich sagen komm wir zum zweiten
effekt allerdings nicht in minecraft ist
und zwar hat mir diesen effekt salih
zugesagt und zwar mal der ich soll in
minecraft ordner gehen dann auf
versionen dann darauf darauf darauf ich
habe euch einfach mal ein bild
eingeblendet mit dem parteitag auch
schon mit drin wo ihr alle sehen könnt
ihr seht ihr die texturen von das ist
ein ordner also da sind die texturen
drin von ganz vielen blöcken wie
beispielsweise in town gras blocken
kaninchen dann kann ich mir nicht mehr
sicher noch ein mops ordner gibt dabei
ist auch egal von von fans ist von
blumen von allem möglichen
und da ist auch ein bild von einem ruby
punkt png oder jpg ich weiß gar nicht
genau ich glaube png und das ist nämlich
ein rubin und zwar ist dieser ruhm ihn
damals hinzugefügt worden
einfach der sollte dass es soll so was
ähnliches wie diamant sein so ein
bisschen daraus kann man sich dann auch
werkzeuge machen und rüstungen und alles
mögliche allerdings wurde er zum letzten
ganz ganz zum ende hin noch mal raus
genommen weil dinner bauen eine rot grün
schwäche hat und dann haben die das
ganze durch den engel der setzt aber
mittlerweile kann man mit ihm redet auch
keine sachen bauen manier anziehen kann
sondern man kann mit dem emerald nur
handeln
allerdings ist der rubin immer noch drin
in minecraft der volt bisher noch nicht
entfernt weil die entwickler dass faul
sind und woran es liegt ob er eventuell
nochmal zugefügt wird wenn ihr dann
genaueres ist einfach und damit in die
kommentare das perfekt nummer zwei und
nummer drei und zwar hat heck nummer
drei auch etwas mit pfeilen zu tun bzw
mit dem bogen und zwar setze ich ja
einfach mal einen tee hin dass es
richtig cool dass diese diese textur
homepage länder
jedenfalls wenn ich einen tmc alter das
sieht ja richtig gehört dass der rat ja
sogar so ein bisschen was raus ist echt
cool breaks fragen ich mag viele was ich
überhaupt für einen text speck nutze was
das überhaupt ist da sind ein paar
gemischte tech speck das hat mir der
just in pixel wolf gemacht das wird
nicht zum download geben weil das ganze
illegal ist das hochzuladen das ganze
allerdings den eigengebrauch zu machen
ist ganz normal kann man ja machen
hochladen dafür das ganze allerdings
nicht jedenfalls wohl perfekt zugesendet
von micos und zwar wenn man gezündet sc
mit dem bogen abschied prallt der pfeil
zurück ich mache jetzt einfach mal in
die endzone das an und ihr seht schon
der fall prallt zurück ich weiß nicht
woran das liegt und ich glaube sogar es
gibt keinen anderen blog ich versichere
mich jetzt hier nicht dafür stehe ich
nicht mit meinem namen
es gibt keinen anderen block der tnt der
feile zurückprallen lässt oder ich bin
mir dabei gar nicht so sicher allerdings
geht ihr schon wenn ich hier ein paar
pfeile gegen schieße beispielsweise und
ich zu denen jetzt an anteilen die fed
auch unter wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise
noch mal drauf schieße prallt der ball
zurück ab zwar nicht mit der gleichen
geschwindigkeit aber er prallt auf jeden
fall ab und die strecke die ja
eigentlich wenn das nicht dagewesen
werde noch geflogen wäre prallt jetzt
quasi zurück ab und das perfekte mal
drei dann kann dich mikos der vierte
feld wurde mir zugeredet von simon kjaer
doktorvater chance wieder kein fekter
minecraft sondern effekt der einfach mal
so ganz interessantes und zwar effect 3
nicht in minecraft bzw
es ist ein zugesendet effect 3 bei mir
nachfolgt 4 in schweden ist minecraft
ein schulfach hier der link zum beweisen
hatte den link gesendet zu onlinewelten
und zwar haben die dort geschrieben
es ist ein zitat es ist ihre welt und
sie genießen es sie lernen etwas über
städteplanung umweltprobleme das war
wirklichen und umsetzen von ideen und
sogar wie man für die zukunft plant so
die lehrerin monika eckmann über das
ungewöhnliche projekt insgesamt 180
schüler nehmen an den lehrstunden mit
minecraft teil und dürfen so während des
offiziellen unterrichts virtuelle welten
errichten dazu angeregt minecraft als
schulfach einzuführen wurde die
verantwortlichen der schule übrigens
durch einen schulwettbewerb namens
futures city in dessen züge in diesem
zuge indes etwas habe ich in dessen zuge
klassen aus ganz schweden vorschläge für
eine bessere zukunft einreichen sollten
auch wen auch wenn auch wenn einige
eltern vorbehalte gegen die pläne hatten
und auch haben möchte die schule
weiterhin an diesem konzept festhalten
sehr zur freude der schüler also die
schüler sind davon überzeugt ich hätte
mich damals auch gefragt wenn das
einfach gewesen wäre und das perfekt
markieren dass auf jeden fall eine
interessante sache freunde bevor wir den
fünf effekt machen es sieht es extrem
coole lehtinen da nochmal eingeblendet
schaut mal was ich da vorne gerade
entdeckt habt da ist unter wasser tempel
wenn ihr rechts seht ihr das ein
bisschen besser dass da diese
konstruktion sind ich fliegt einmal so
ein bisschen hin damit den titel in der
städter in prey und hier vorne wisst ihr
noch dahin bin ich gespannt ist das
ganze tnt explodiert und so das ist
schon krass lisa zieht allerdings wenn
der fünfte effekt zugesendet von tiger
tiger creme tiger krippen oder irgendwie
so uns war hat er mit zugesendet dass es
keine fohlen mehr in minecraft gibt in
minecraft wirklich steht das noch dass
es holen gibt und dass ich dich cool auf
mit diesem flüstere ich auch so okay der
fluss fließt nicht runter jetzt fließt
der fluss wunder es gibt keine fohlen
mehr und zwar wenn man ich bin ich ja
normalerweise ich zeige euch das mal
hier beispielsweise mit einem schwein
wenn ich ein schwein ihm und ich glaub
das schwein draufkommt einen baby
schweige markt mit navi schauen sie das
baby schwein werde ich dann
beispielsweise eine kuh nehme und ich
packe das darauf das hat mir schon mal
nachfolge
dann habe ich hier eine baby co wenn ich
das allerdings mit einem pferd mache es
gibt keine baby felder mehr es ist gibt
nur noch dann die gleichen pferde die da
rauskommen ich kann jetzt ein anderes
pferd nehmen dann kommt hier auch wieder
das gleiche pferd raus und ihr seht
schon ich habe es nur diese zwei
verschiedenen bereichen auf diese fährte
des rechts gemacht habe aber es ist
nicht so dass wenn ich hier so ein pferd
ab das dann davon ein baby bekommen
sondern ich bekomme quasi einfach immer
nur die gleichen pferde wenn ich jetzt
rein gesät ihr meine welt ist voll mit
pferden und das ist ein bisschen komisch
also es gibt nicht mehr fohlen
es gibt auch keine fohlen wenn man die
ganzen tiere hier überhaupt dann geht es
nämlich auch keine polen ist ein
bisschen komisch das ist jedenfalls
factor 5 wenn euch diese folge gefallen
hat würde ich mich definitiv über eine
bewertung freuen das zeigt mir dass sie
die serie feiert dass sie mehr wollte
das dienstag wieder eine folge kommen
soll
sein kontrakt china.com dann sehen uns
in der nächsten video wieder